uhoh I forgot to update the stream title
didn't
I let's try
that update the stream title
oops all
right
welcome I did a little bit of work on
this over the weekend just a
little nothing too fancy
let me tweet this out and
um give will a little bit of [ __ ] one
second
hold
[Laughter]
on let's see if he
[Music]
oh this is so
funny okay let's get started on the MOBA
Dev let's get started on the MOBA
Dev I gotta have a little bit of fun
right okay um so let me talk about what
I did over the the weekend here with
config there have been uh a few
changes you could say but most of them
not to the Moa I did like a lot of
changes to everything else a lot of
refactors and stuff okay
um the main thing with the Moa is I
figured out a new way of doing uh
targeting where is it
uh right puffer
lib
oan H it's still so funny I got will
foring streaming every day
now Will's cool will does uh he's done a
lot of work oh there you are there you
are you came back you came over to get
back back at
me this is no cursor man this is this is
like two plugins Neo them one of them is
super Maven but it's for completing one
line at a time because python doesn't
have good LSPs that's
it so I figured out uh I figured out
over the weekend a way better way of
doing targeting I was trying to figure
out how to implement a linked list in
scon without Malik which was God awful
uh and then I just figured out a better
way of doing it so uh
scan where is it scan AOE okay
so this thing returns a beant which is
whether it's scanned anything or not and
this does a loop over the nearby area
and it has a whole bunch of flags for
how you want to filter the data okay so
you have this singular scan function and
then when you want to actually do
something over the scanned uh the scan
things it is way way way way easier
because you can do like AOE scanned for
instance and you can just go over 200 is
hardcoded for now it's just the max
number of scan things and it'll just go
over targets until it finds a null
Terminator and it will grab the scan
Target decide whether to hit it and move
on so you get rid of this nested Loop
over nearby area being repeated all over
the code base now it's just scan based
so this is very nice um we're going to
do something really cool today which I
think will work at least I haven't come
up with a reason that it shouldn't work
and what that is is we are going to
we're going to implement a star
pathing but we're going to cash it for
everything
so what we're going to do the map is
128 by
128 so that squared is like I don't know
150 was it no
15,000 yeah which is not that big so
essentially you're going to end up with
a 128
by no a what is it is it 10,000 by 10
hold on I might be wrong here let me let
me figure this out so
it's 128 time
128 oh yeah yeah times 128 time
expected I don't think that's too bad
though is
it 268
so let me think let me say what I was
going to do here
um I want to precompute the pathing from
every single tile to every single other
tile so you pick you know where you are
currently you pick where you want to go
hey JBL uh I this is actually I think
the thing that you
recommended right is to pre-compute the
AAR pathing so
so the good news is that we can do it uh
we can do it but I think it's 268
megabytes of
data which maybe is not that
bad I don't know if we can get that into
scon easily we'll see
but
so if we precompute from every single
position in the map to every single
other position in the map right that
is I mean it's 128x 128 by 128 by 128
right it's like your
XY and technically we can prune some
stuff out but I think it would make the
uh the data format worse
so h i mean this shouldn't be that bad
though right because wait if we want to
do all paths right if we want to do all
paths so from any part of the map to any
other part of the map then we don't need
AAR right we just need breath for
search is there anything anything else
clever that we can do
here is there any other clever way that
we can save on
this cuz
like
H so naively right what I can do is I
can run breath ver search uh 128 time
128 so I can run breath first search
16,000 times on this map uh as long as I
implement this in SC it will be
relatively
fast and then I can save that data to a
file and then I will have pre-computed
optimal pathing for the whole
map it will be 268 megabytes assuming I
use one byte uh to represent like the
the path direction that you're going to
take in any one
location technically I could cut this
down by a factor of
four because I only need two bits per uh
I only need two bits per Direction so
technically if I want to be really
sweaty with this
right I can do this in 67 MB because I
can have each bite could contain uh you
only need 0 1 two three to tell you like
up down left right which is two
bits but before we consider that level
of optimization cuz that's kind of
obnoxious we got to do bit reads
um there might be a better way of doing
this I'm just trying to think is there
like if I go from point A to point B
right
and I go to like some point in the
middle along the way then I already know
the optimal point from that one to the
end right
is there some algorithm I don't know
about I'm going to chat GPT this just to
see if I'm being
stupid
um this is really nice just I only ever
use this for like I'm not going to
expect this to solve the problem for me
cuz it's not it's just if there is an
existing algorithm that I don't know
about that will do this so
I need to compute uh optimal pathing on
a uh a 2d grid with
obstacles from every point to every
other
point is
there uh I can run
BFS from every
start and get this but that is o n 4 for
memory for the
result
there a better
algorithm Floyd
Marshall
ooh AAR doesn't help AAR is a faster
algorithm for getting from one point to
another point we need all points so this
is exactly the type of thing I was
looking for from chat
jity
um they say that they have o of n cubed
time and O of N squared
memory where n is the number
of oh I think that they're stupid they
redefined n hold on I think that this is
stupid well wait if this is chat GPT
being wrong though then this is exactly
the type of thing I'm talking about um
hold on let me just let me confirm that
I'm right here distance
Matrix i
j
[Music]
distances okay dynamic programming thing
so this is literally worse isn't
it wait what the hell this is worse
right
regarded it works both
ways in this context would
indeed hold on let me see if this
algorithm looks like it's good though
distance IJ is min of
what I think this is the same as breath
for
search wait I J no no no ik
how is this n cubed
lot how the hell is this ever better
than breath for search wait Floyd
warshall this is freaking chat GPT
wasting my time as every time freaking
everyone on the internet saying it's
going to solve everything but it can't
solve
anything all pair shortest path problem
for weighted
graphs well this is the actual thing oh
perfect this is what I wanted
here all equals pair yeah that's what I
need I need all pairs I have the all
pair shortest path problem
exactly unweighted graphs undirected
graphs
complexity does anybody smart here know
if there's
actually anything that's
um better for this problem so look this
is the problem that I have let me
explain to you
I'll explain the problem
so does this let me
draw where is
it where's the just the draw tool on
this stupid
thing oh my gosh why I can never
freaking
find draw tool canvas draw
online D all these things are so bad why
why is there literally just nothing but
it's oh my God all these apps are so
bad okay this is what I
wanted
right like
this
so from any point to any other point
let's say that there's an obstacle like
in the way let's say that there's like
obstacles here right then the optimal
path
is it it's can ties can be broken
arbitrarily so this is an optimal path
right but I need all pairs all points
from any start to any destination on
this map
so uh and I need the the direction so
basically the output of this thing I
want is I want to have something that
tells me from any starting point which
direction I need to move
in uh to have the optimal path towards
the end
goal which should exactly be all PA of
shortest paths
um does anything have less than n squ
memory no get out of the
windows does anything have less
than wait every pair of vertices V
am I wrong or is running breath for
search not just
faster
wait pair of
vertices am I dumb or is breath for
search just faster
see Johnson's
algorithm on Spar it's not
weighted all pairs would be doing a lot
of repe that's what I would think
right um but
is I would think that it's redoing a lot
of work but apparently there this is not
a thing like I don't know if there's an
algorithm for this
last this is the last search I'm going
to do otherwise it's just wasting my
time
could you not use the Waypoint to your
advantage
here only really need the optimal path
from a point in a particular region to
the nearest weight so that's true for
the creeps um but the advantage here is
that like I'm going to be able to if I
have this if I make this nav grid thing
this is going to be so much better
because here like I can make you as a
player you can click a point and then
it'll there for you like I can do stuff
like that I can make scripted agents so
much more easily if I have this because
pathing is just
solved and to give you a to be clear
here pathing is incredibly incredibly
solved if I do it this way because like
it's literally a lookup like you like
say okay I'm at this cell I want to go
to this target I look up in a table I
look up the direction I go I go there
it's 0 of one so pathing becomes o of
one okay chat GPT produced
garbage it cannot solve anything it
cannot recognize when it has nothing to
add chat GPT is garbage thank you for
wasting my
time as always
garbage every
time let's make uh this C test thing
in that case maybe you could compute
that giant MAV that giant nav mesh wants
but dynamically load relevant chunks
into memory based on spatial well I was
just going to mmap the
file
um I was just going to mmap the file
though frankly like I could just load it
into memory
well yeah I can totally just load it
right yeah
so the the one trick I'm going to have
to do is like you're going to want to
simulate a whole bunch of instances of
this game in parallel right so like here
a very common workflow that I'll have uh
is that I'll try to get a batch of 4096
agents so 10 agents per map I need to
run 400 games of uh 400 mug instances at
the same time and then usually I do that
on a couple different cores so let's say
I have 800 MOBA
instances
um I don't want to have 250 megabytes
per instance right I want to share it
across them so that'll be like mildly
annoying to figure out but not that not
that bad
let's stop yapping and start coding
we're going to start with this in uh
we're going to start with this in Python
and then we're going to Port it to we're
going to Port it to C after that uh it's
not going to be that hard to Port so
what we're going to do is we're going to
start with data
equal let's do uh what is
it Def
precompute
pathing and we'll do a
grid and that's it
right
so.
shape
zero uh it's going to be square so we
don't really care about other stuff
and we can prune a little bit by the way
we'll be able to prune just a little bit
based on obstacles so it'll be a little
faster to
compute maybe 50%
faster uh so we start with the grid
shape
and
storage was it was it
optimal what is it
optimal paths
equal
Zer n *
n nodes nodes
u8 we'll do it this way for now we might
do bit packing later we'll
is I don't like doing nodes like this
actually I think think it should be nnn
and N
right that's
easier yeah nnn and N so it's going to
be
like you know X1 y1 or like y1 X1 Y2 X2
something like
that
for what did we do X and
Y we'll do R in range of n or C in range
of n and we'll do uh path we'll do uh
breath for search grid Paths
call and then a row comma
call that's
good Cent
paths breath first
search oh is this just going to do it
for me
I don't like that this is recursive
that's
stupid actually I think that's not just
stupid I think that's wrong breath first
search should not be a recursive
algorithm
right can breath first no breath first
search shouldn't even be able to be
recursive
right did it just Implement depth first
search and call it breath first search
is I just saw a tweet today by the way
that's like hey next year the math
Olympiad winner is going to be a
language
model maybe we should start by teaching
it a first year computer
science that might be better thing to
do okay so if the grid is zero then we
return no wait zero
is hold
on I'm getting confused by how I I want
to implement this now
the nice thing with breath first search
is it's always
efficient so the frontier is always the
shortest
path
H we're exposing today how truly bad I
am at algorithms problems in elak code
style
crap so this is going to take me an
embarrassing L long time but uh I think
the final result will be nice
so there is a lot of redone U of work
being recomputed
here but essentially what I want to pass
is I want breath for search to pass
the first action that you took so the
first direction that you went
in so that whenever you get to a new
node you fill in you fill in the table
with the the direction that you took
initially from the first step to get to
that node does that make sense so
like when you pathfind from a specific
starting point
the only thing that we care about is the
first action that you
took
yeah that makes sense
I think that you have to
enq the first four
moves right you have to enue the first
four
moves
so it's going to be like move up
equals
zero uh and then Dr is1
column is zero move down is going to
be index is
one left is going to
be
[Music]
01 then move right so this is going to
be these are your first
actions I was actually excited to do
this today I have no idea why it was
because I'm terrible at these types of
problems um but it's going to be real
cool and it works this is going to be
like ludicrously fast
believe and
also we're not going to be able to use
this data structure
right we're not going to be able to use
this data
structure we'll do it this way for now
though just to test it we're going to
have to replace this with like numpy Ray
pop the new position that you're going
to go to is the
original
plus like
this and
uh does this give you a stack or a q
wait I think it's a stack by default
right
yeah that's not a that's a
stack by
default so we're going to have to do
something because this will be depth for
search but we can we can shift it around
a little
bit
um we'll just have to prepend okay
that's fine
does python actually treat them
differently treat what differently stack
and
Q uh we're using a list and lists work
as
Stacks right if you
append obviously stacks and q's have
different methods well this is neither
this is just a list you can use a list
in python as a stack just by default
because it has fast depends and fast
pops well fast for python right but you
can do like a. append or and then a. pop
and a stack order right but then if you
want to do it as a lit like it's not
fast if you want to use it as a q
doesn't matter it's all slow because
it's python right but you have to do a
equals
like you know four plus a
right and now this is a
interesting so it makes inferences about
what no it doesn't make any inferences
whatsoever we're
just it it's just the fact that lists
have like this is not a stack or a que
it's a list right and the way that the
list structure is implemented relatively
for python it has o of one I believe o
of one appens and O of one pop from the
end of the list so that's what you need
for a stack right is that you append and
then you pop you get that same element
it's fifo uh if you want to do a q you
have to when you add elements you have
to add them to the start and that is a
slow operation python does have cues and
stuff built in that we could use that
would just give this us this anyways but
in reality we're going to end up using a
numpy array anyways for all of this
because these oper are not scon and we
have to process uh 200 some odd million
elements so I don't want to wait for
python to do that and syon is
fun okay so if the grid is
blocked then we continue
otherwise yeah I'm following now I
thought pop was
taking out
elements from the other end and then
when you appended it swapped to the oh
no no no yeah no it's not that
yeah technically the way we're doing
this now if you click on an obstacle
it's not going to
work but don't click on obstacles
right
well maybe we could fix that doesn't
scon work with
deck if it does that's news to me I
don't think so
I'm pretty sure that list and decks and
all the python data types will not be
accelerated we're going to end up having
to what we're going to end up doing is
I'm going to just allocate a big numpy
array and we're just going to
like we're going to add stuff into it
and then read stuff from the other
side I breath for search I think is is
pretty easy to
implement that way you just pre-allocate
a big buffer of uh however many elements
that you need right and you keep a
pointer to where you've written them and
you just keep writing down into the
array it it's pretty easy to implement
your own uh your own Q structure so
that's probably what we're going to
do okay so we set the grid to be the
action so what we're saying is that if
you're starting in at RNC and you want
to get to this new position then the
first move that you take is action right
EC
down
[Music]
uhhuh and then we
append move up does this do
it we're obviously we're going to have
to like draw this on a grid or something
to see if it
works this is actually so critical to
the code that I don't and this is kind
of a fun project so I don't mind
spending a little bit of time on this
today so we might we might even make
like a cool little demo with
that actually I wrote a renderer over
the weekend that'll be perfect for this
so This actually shouldn't even be hard
to make a cool demo
right so that we just run this
once and
that I think we can do this even more
cleanly let's just write a little test
function so we'll do
test BFS
right and this will just take
grid and then this will take R1 C1
R2
C2 then we'll do
N grid.
Shape uh and then we'll
do paths equal not this we only need
this one we only need a 2d one
and then we do breath birst
search from
there and then what we do
do while the points are not the
same loved your thesis defense used as
an
inspiration for
my Viva
not sure what that is but thank you
appreciate the
support um we're doing some cool high
performance well not yet at the moment
very low performance but in a few hours
very very high performance pathfinding
for this new Mobis Sim I'm working on
for
RL it's like what if we had DOTA but it
ran at a million steps per second
okay
so while the destination is not the
start then what we do
is undergraduate the assist fense okay
cool yeah
um it's going to get a lot easier to
work in this space soon as well
like it's going to get a lot easier to
do work in this space because we're
going to have a lot of these simulations
I'm working on building them they're
going to be way way way faster than ever
before and they're going to be way way
way simpler than ever before it's just
going to be all good things all
around so what would we do we do bre for
search right
um is it possible to make a model that
can be able to scrap through out the
scrape the internet to get information
about any person
just by showing his
image is it possible yes am I going to
help you make a doxing tool no
I think I did this kind of weird didn't
I
[Music]
well yeah cuz I can't actually get the
optimal path from
this yeah right because it's it's from
the starting point so you can't get the
optimal path uh from just one call to
breath ver search the way I've
implemented it but you can get the
vector field so let's just get the
vector field instead
do I mean it's just like that's clearly
a thing that would be very very heavily
abused right yeah you can think of a
bajillion instances for like a thing to
use that like would be fine for that but
that's just
like I mean that leads more heavily
towards missiles than you know rocket
ships to the Moon right
and mind you I'm not usually somebody
who cares a ton about dual use
either like generally if I see an
application that has a ton of potential
for misuse but can also do a bunch of
good stuff I'll be very much in the camp
of building it that one seems like very
obviously like like I can't even think
of that many good things that you would
want to do with that
okay so we can't build this this way we
need to
do we need to draw a vector field
right ah let's just like draw Vector
field right
so obnoxious how this thing
is we have to write a little rib render
now don't
we yeah we totally have to write a ray
vectorfield renderer
right that's
obnoxious well it doesn't have to be
fast so that's not that bad
yeah Vector field is in every grid on
the map shows an arrow towards the
destiny yeah like something like that
this is just a very like this is just
one of those cases where like I could
YOLO it and just try to like run this
but it's very likely that I'll have
messed this up and it's going to take me
a while
grid oh
16 pathf finding from every node
possible yeah exactly
that this would not be considered very
smart this would be considered me taking
10 times longer than is needed on entry
level Elite code
[ __ ]
um unfortunately I know how to I know
how to build lots of cool things I do
not know how to solve tricky problems
quickly that is not something I am good
I mean the strategy to test an isolation
instead of integr yeah
yeah and I don't usually write tests I
don't usually write like the isolated
test this is one of the things where
like you have to you got to test it and
you not only have to test it you have to
visualize it
I get to show this off now because we're
going to use some of this code I wrote
this over the weekend it's really
cool so I wrote this puffer lib Ray
renderer
Advent of code every year and
pathfinding always screws me
over I mean basically
anything any tricky algorithms problem
that's unintuitive and that is only done
quickly by people grinding leite code
will screw me over because I don't grind
elak
code never
have like you can't you cannot say that
these things are intuitive they simply
are not
so let's see if this works I'll get just
show off the render that I made this
weekend okay
so this thing right looks very similar
to the one from before doesn't it boom
we've got Zoom we've got fast Zoom we've
got
pan we've got a little help menu if I
hit tab that shows FPS and
stuff excuse me are you suggesting that
there are more valuable uses of your
time
absolutely like making ridiculous mobas
and renderers for them so this is a nice
little thing right little smooth pan and
zoom thing quits on Escape here's the
source here's the source code right
here that's it just this one little
block
here it's pretty
nice pause and then over a node to see
the
stats that would be cool that would be
substantially more work
I think we can just use this thing and
add some code
well this is wrong it should just be
grid. shape it's completely wrong
actually do shape one grid. shape zero
and then tile size here with equal grid.
shape oh my gosh this is so bad the way
that this is width
height tile size
suggestions okay there we go that's the
client
right
okay let's start with
this and then what we're going to do is
we're just going to add the vector field
underneath it
what happened down
there
oops oh yeah this is garbage we don't
need this
obviously we need to do
uh we need to put some data in here
don't
we why don't
we let's load up like a crop of the the
DOTA map
let's load up a crop of the DOTA
map that'll be
here game map path is just going to
be uh
open go to map don't need this
and then this is going to be
well this is called stuck in a while
loop I guarantee
you yep that's stuck in a while loop so
that's infinitely looping code which is
wonderful ah right so this
um this array that we make this needs
Sentinels so we're going to put this as
NE uh Zer minus one and then we're going
to
say uh if
grid is not is uh equal
to1 then you
continue and this is why we test what is
the current state of the project the
current state of the project object
good oops I forgot I have keyboard not
Mouse control so you've got your creep
waves fighting they fight each other
reasonably they attack Towers you got
your three lanes you've got Heroes the
heroes aren't doing much they're kind of
chilling at spawn I wrote this little
renderer over the weekend it is playable
as well though I think I might have
broken a few things we'll
see oh it looks
good some improvements to be made here
but this is the current state of the
project I will save you puffers
and I
die not bad for one week of work
apparently ah this is not supposed to be
R is this supposed to be
R2
wait
this is supposed to be
paths equal to this and then this is
also suppos path is equal to
this this thing is evidently still
looping
140,000 yeah that's too big
so what do RNC
represent this is the uh the starting
position you breath for search from a
starting
position so
in you pop from the
Q well first of all this Q append is
wrong remember remember I said this had
to be breath first search so this should
actually
be this should be plus
Q do you need to be tracking visited
nodes right
here oh wait if it's equal to negative 1
this should be not equal to Nega 1
okay that actually breath bir
searched that breath first searched
correctly now but it did it uh quit very
soon unexpected keyword tile
keyword Rd renderer does not take a tile
size at
all uh I don't know how this happened
actually didn't I do the signature
correctly
boom index
255 is out of bounds with for a is
zero super Maven got you and you were
talking so you didn't notice
yep am I on the Pro Plan here by the
way
upgrade I don't know what's the
versioning thing
updated okay maybe it's better now I
don't
running self.
colors of
grid what do I have on the grid though
hold on maybe I I just have something
dumb
here
0255 let's see so game map
there
boom
inverted yeah
yeah hell yeah look at
this we've got our little
render and now we can uh we can do some
breath bir search let's do zero
zero and uh 31 31 that's pretty good
right or no it's 60 we did 60 so it
should be 63 63 Maybe
oh uh wait no you're still dumb aren't
you
because oh R2 and C2 don't get used
obviously um so this doesn't even
matter but how
uh feeling very very
quickly so if the paths is not equal to1
and
continue okay
so we get
R2 1
0 paths is equal to 2
55 ah we made it a u
8 a u 8 is not
good so paths will have to
be plus 255 will have to be our
sentinel oh
that looks
nice look at that we got all sorts of
stuff very
nice though it doesn't seem to be
correct but at least we have some
equal uh grid. shape of zero C is equal
to this I don't know what it just even
tried to fill in here this is
garbage um we need self. to
size TI size
paths okay and we need to do a draw
Arrow rayb draw
Arrow do we have
mildly obnoxious that we have to do it
this way but
um this is correct
there's no draw Arrow function I guess
there wouldn't be
right so this is going to
be so it's going to
be X+
TS okay so the positions
we need to
do so X Plus Ts over
two and then Y is going to be the same I
think
right and then it's going to
be x
+
three y+ tile size oh yeah this is a
triangle right x +
2/3
pause one now this position has to be uh
down so it's going to
right do I trust super
Maven no idea if I trust super Maven
but
do does it have a built-in rotate
function it does but it has it for
textures I believe
so we're going to do r. draw
triangle and we're not going to do
colors. Violet we're going to give it
like a reasonable color which why don't
we use the
uh oh it's I think 178 is puffer color
so R
178 178 255 I think this is our
color puffer
color and of course we also have to do a
r begin
draw begin
drawing clear
background no we don't clear the
background we have to leave the
background let's see if this does
anything
well this is not quite what we
intended it's very
flickery I would love to know why it's
very
cool can I begin drawing twice what if I
do it here
flickers no it has a frame rate but it
should batch
everything at least I would think it
should batch everything we can give it a
different frame rate
this oh I guess it's
um that's weird
well I know why I know why it's
happening it's because it's the draw
calls there's an end drawing call in the
renderer before
annoying I mean for now I can just patch
this
right I can just
anymore which is
cool and uh we can also we can just not
have the FPS be
garbage which will be nice for being
able to play with
this but unfortunately I didn't remember
to scale this
though yeah it should be scaled
correctly at the start
more or
less let's figure out why the pathf
finding is
grid if the grid is zero then what we do
is you set the paths
to
five set it to
five you
continue do
anything cannot access local variable
pause
again other way around
maybe oh there we
go it looks like I'm offset a little bit
but uh this is what we want right very
close do
it why are we offset one tile
again I think why we're offset a
tile so this is if it's
Y X Plus TI size over
three plus tile
cords I don't know why it's offset like
this it's
weird well figure that out in a
moment can we figure out why um it's all
facing
zero oh wait we can totally yeah if we
do pop zero like this we can totally use
this as a q so we can do Q
dot append move up move down move left
and move right like
this still doesn't give us any unique
actions so very
it one one and Z what happened to move
up
oh well you can't move up
obviously because you're in the
corner so that's actually
with move down and then move to the
right yeah that's
correct so what
happens okay the path is equal to action
right
move up down left
right get
right q.
POP Hold
on so here's your Q
right move
so the move
is
one one and
zero and then it's going to go through
move left and we should end up at move
right we do end up at move right three Z
and one
action so that actually looked good to
me let's see how the path looks after we
have computed the path
here we can actually just do that right
uh right here so let's see what our path
looks like
ah we do actually have various symbols
here I see a couple threes at the
top okay and three should be moved to
the right so if action is equal to three
maybe our draw function is wrong let me
see so the draw function for a move to
the right yeah this is totally wrong
right this should
be X
and then this should
be still
x y + tile
size 3 so 2 * tile size over
three right and then we should have uh
the last corner of the triangle should
be X Plus tile
size and then y plus pile size over two
so this should be your correct
triangle Ah that's better so it's not
perfect yet but
look we see we have some triangle going
on here something is is reasonable over
here uh
so let's maybe fix the
remainder of these
triangles so zero should be pointed down
right so for a down
triangle X Plus TI
size well this is these are
flipped let's see if this
better okay so this is now in the
correct position but it's still flipped
let's see what's wrong with our uh our
zero
triangle uh it's that super M completely
got it wrong
okay
so X Plus to size over
two
why
wait yeah this is just completely bogus
right yeah so this is X Plus to size
over three
Y X plus two times T it's not that hard
really and then y
then X
Plus TI size over
two and then
y plus to
size do I still have this stupid thing
upside
down I still have it upside down don't
I um
am I crazy or should this be a down a
downfacing
arrow unless the coordinate system is
backwards which doesn't appear to
be this is where we're drawing isn't
it oh apparently not thought that this
was what the uh the action
now what
happened what happened
happen X Plus tile size over 3 Y X + 2 *
TI size over
five so wait this is XY so it's 5
10 and then 8 and six this looks like a
valid triangle to
me uh Why is drawing shapes this hard
is
ridiculous should not be this
no you don't it's not closed this should
be
fine how' I do it for this
one is there like a rule of like the
order you have to draw them in or
something like that like maybe you have
to draw them around like the the right
way I I bet you have to like draw them
around the right
way vertex in clock in
counterclockwise yeah that it was it's
literally this so it's counterclockwise
order so you have to go around the other
way so it's got to
be uh 2 * tile size over
three TI size over
three well if you think of about it it's
got to know how to
shade I mean I was it's I was correct
look it's literally the thing I just
said right
so the obnoxious thing is I can't even
tell you if this is wrong or
not
right because remember this is drawing
the
um the first move
okay yeah this is probably actually
correct because the thing is this is the
first move what it's drawing is that is
for every position on the map it's
drawing the first move that you would
take from the origin to get there
right so yeah all of the other positions
except the ones at the top you can see
that you have to go directly right if if
you want to go directly right but the
other ones are all
like
yeah uh I could give it a better
starting position
maybe where would like a cool place to
start this
be I don't know I'll start in the middle
and see what it does
Okay cool so if you start it in the
middle uh which is like right here is I
think a couple of these being empty is
weird
middle I don't know exactly where you
start
it let's actually let's uh let's draw a
red square on that
it's I don't know what's happening on
the left
here oh probably just our left facing
triangle is drawn wrong
right yeah probably our left facing
triangle is uh is just drawn wrong
two so our left facing triangle
is you start
counterclockwise so let's do
x y + tile size over 3
yeah we just have to flip
yeah
awesome almost
there uh I would like to
change i' would like the initial
position to be
empty so let's do that let's do
and this should be we'll set this equal
to
five uh which is our
KN and then let's
see okay perfect so
it this looks like a valid breath for a
search so you have to remember this is
not the vector field pointing towards
the Target right this is uh for every
Target position on the map this is if I
start at the center what is the first
move I should make to get to that Target
and I think that this works so okay what
we're going to do next is we're going
to optimize this in Python first such
that it will be easy toonize then we're
going toonize it then we're going to get
the actual maps that we care
about let's do
that and we'll also rethink a couple
little data structures uh along the way
but I think that I have it correct at
the moment even though it makes it more
Awkward to draw I think it's going to be
easier to use I'll be back in a minute
and then we'll set we'll work on
so it's occurring to me that we might be
able to index a little
differently so right now I have it start
position it's start row start call end
end row end
call what would happen if I tried to
compute this
as end row end call comma start row
start call what happens then
I have to slightly rewrite this then cuz
the breath for search has to start from
the
destination and it has to go to the the
starting
position that means though that a single
breath for search call gets me the uh
the optimal path to a Target which is
more reasonable and it should be better
for cash coherency as well because
otherwise you're um you always want to
keep the first you know indices or
whatever the same if you can and you
want the last index to be the variable
one
so if I do it this way then the desk row
desk call always stay the same so I
think it's better for cash coherency and
it's better for
visualization because it makes a lot
more sense
right if you think about it as you have
a map that tells you how to get to every
position rather than you have a map that
tells you the move that you make at any
given position
to get you to the next position that's
closest yeah that's way better so let's
refactor it like that then do the then
we'll get a good Vector map that'll be
cool to look at I can post that
online
code this should be start
R start C so we do backwards breath
resarch let's actually break it out as
well because you can't do multiple lines
you can't multiple line it like this in
continue start R if it's not
empty start
R start R is
five Paths of start r it's going to be
um now we have to flip these values
don't
we I think this is going to be backwards
we're going to see
backwards so let's first of all we'll
flip
these now it should Point towards the
target so this is how you get to the the
Target
right uh and now instead of making it
the first
move we're going to put
action say
zero 1
three you know I don't know why we uh we
worry so much about this this is really
just
easy I don't know why we worry about
pathf finding it's uh it's easy
right now
um there's one minor little issue with
this right
which is that
technically well first of all these it
gives you this really wonky pathing like
this because it doesn't do
diagonals and uh second of all like
these agents can technically move on a
continuous
grid yeah they can technically move on a
continuous grid but we can do discreet
pathf finding right for the creeps let's
just um
let's like add diagonals
in
right yeah let's just add in
diagonals and that should be pretty much
close enough
right because if they can just do
diagonals then like they should be able
to learn do the diagonal and then do the
shortest like straight line or something
they're not going to be able to pathfind
you know
perfectly not going to be able to
pathfind perfectly but it'll look pretty
reasonable I would
say it'll be really
close is that going to look weird
you're going to look weird if they uh
they only move eight
directional I don't think it'll look
that
weird a pretty minor limitation
honestly and this is just for scripted
agents as well and creeps that's not a
problem it's fine this'll look way
cooler let's fix it so
we actually get to make this way simpler
now
um because all we have to do
continue equal to action hold
on I'm trying to figure out a way to not
have to do this logic twice
this is always the obnoxious thing with
algorithms like this is figuring out how
to roll the initial condition into the
main Loop so you don't have to write it
twice and have it be
gross
um let's see so
we can just okay I know how to do it so
we're going to get rid of this I'd
say uh we're going to just have the Q be
equal to uh
zero z
z which is the initial position
right and then what we're going to do is
we're going to set this
Paths of d r d c at the very end to be
five so we just null that last action
and then what we do is we just uh we pop
from the Q we get the action and the
Delta start R start
C it's an obstacle set it to five that's
good you set it to be the
action yeah which is fine it doesn't
matter and now what we just do is we
just append uh lots of things so q.
append so we're going to do action index
is going to be
zero uh this is going to be Dr
minus one
DC
Dr minus one Dr +
DC Dr minus one Dr + one so this is up down left right but we
one so this is up down left right but we
really want to do
I like this up down left right being
like
this I'm trying to think if there's a
clever way I can Index
this it's eight
actions not really
huh well that's
okay we'll just do it this way
so we'll do up down left
right and then we'll do q.
append or and then this will be
right now the only thing we have to
figure out is now how to draw these
freaking
triangles
um be really nice if I could find
a decent way of doing this let me think
there really isn't a good way of doing
this is there I think I just have to
write out all the bloody triangle
definitions
yeah
well that
sucks
yeah so these ones were correct I
think what if I just like let super
Maven do it and then I try to fix
right yep
[Music]
slop love my slop yep
good
job was there a function that I can use
that will be just like better than
this I don't think so right draw a ring
draw ring Lines line strip
bezier
uh no I think
cool to see they have Collision
functions in there I didn't know
that
so is this
um let's see if these ones are still
correct
oops else okay we got to take this out
hold
on okay so these ones are correct these
are just the uh the straight the
straightaway actions
right kind of weird but I think they're
valid
and then we'll do if action is equal to
four remember I have to go in the
opposite direction of these which is
very confusing to think
about so
Dr minus
one so it's pointing that way so I have
to point the other way
so God that's so hard to think about
*
TS
y
x y +
TS and
then HTS my
head
plus three
and this is supposed to be a
three
okay
and five is Dr + 1 DC + one so it points
this way so I got to go that
way so what
that's the the first point is easy it's
just
XY then we've got to go around counter
counterclockwise
which is going to
be x + 2 * tile size over
3 y + tile
size and
then X Plus tile size y
+ 2 * T size over
three okay and then six is Dr + 1 DC so
it goes that way so we got to go that
way
um counterclockwise so it's X Plus TI
size what this one yeah six X Plus TI
size y That's the top right corner then
we got to do X Plus TI
size no it's just
x y + 2 * to size over
three and then it's going to be X+
T size over three
y all right one more so Dr minus one
goes that way it's the bottom right
corner facing one we flip
it bottom right corner facing one is
going to be X Plus T size over
three
y
x TI size over
three and X Plus tile size
y plus to
yeah well that's almost it that's
actually pretty darn good for a first
try uh I don't know why some of these
are
blue assumedly I did something
backwards but these ones look good so
the one that's facing to the top right
is not good getting
rendered top right should be they're
flipped so
it's it's the one that faces this way
which is minus which is one and minus
one I
think so which one is this
one which one's one minus
one six did I do six
right so I put it top right
corner and then I did
X Y is down
here then
X Plus tile
and
uh yeah only problem is that it we're
covering obstacles as well for some
reason so maybe let's not freaking do
that
um if
the grid
oh we can't give it five because five is
an action value now so we have to give
this eight so we'll do our heldout value
will be eight
it does allow you to go through a corner
size gaps and
walls which I thought I think is kind of
funny honestly that it allows you to do
that I don't really care about that do
I if a wall is one thick like
that I can just touch up the map to have
two thick walls
did my bit rate just drop a
bunch looks like it
did hopefully we should be good
now
um
okay
so something weird just happened to some
of my arrows
though no I think they're
good some just not you know they're not
all the same sizes it's no big
Fields maybe you can pad all
obstacles so in real time the agents
don't pat long wall yeah that's what I
was going to
do
um I that's
easy I can just feather the walls if I
just feather all the walls one pixel
that will fix it so I might just touch
up the map essentially that's no big
deal literally you feather the walls one
pixel it's
fixed but this is nice a good
result uh now do I dare try to run this
on the full size map I think I do right
let me let me just see if I can do so I
set a big tile size for this didn't I
not really this is
eight can we see what's going on
here kind
of what if I now do the full sizee map
kind of hard to see what's going
on can I do like 12
maybe to size
12 maybe that looks
and I should do like the enemy base
right this would be a cool position to
do which is like 16 hold
16 uh Wrong Way Around 128 - 16 this is
y right so I flipped Y and X this is 16
128 minus
16 and we'll do a little bit further in
it looks like so this is like
yeah how to get to the enemy
base in your base killing your
dudes you just follow the vector field
from anywhere right so like this way
this way this way
y this way this
way this way this way and we're in your
base killing your
let's do
uh render do
render uh we'll
do turn I need to import the other thing
from render
right what is it
uh hold
on going to have a cool thing for
Twitter renderer do Ren
C data to
numai C data to
nump data to
numpy like
so and then we will
do image or this is a
[Music]
we have to import pill here
right import
change let's see if this works first but
I think that we're going to do something
cooler before we tweet it
do we get
pathing yeah
so Okay so we've got that
PNG
um well we can tweet this
first that'll be nice you got to tweet
more stuff so that you people see
it puffer
marketing got to do your open source
marketing after all
PNG let's see how this
looks very
frame good time to remind folks to Star
Puffer lib if they enjoy this stuff
helps me out a whole bunch
we've got will who is going to
absolutely refuse to end the stream
before I do meaning that we're both
going to be here
forever okay so this is actually pretty
solid
um we now need to make this
fast yeah cuz this needs to run like
10,000 times and I don't feel like this
taking forever to
pre-compute question is how fast do I
need this
so literally all I have to do is uh use
a numpy array
right isn't it that
easy because it's a q right
yeah stack would be a stack would be
substantially more
obnoxious but because it's a q it's
actually pretty
easy so we're going to give this um grid
paths uh this is going to get a
buffer and let's take this
buffer so this is going to be kind of
cool and instructive this is how you
make
stuff super
fast like 100x
faster okay so
buffer
zeros the buffer needs to be able to
accommodate n * n is the number of uh
tiles and then three which is the action
row call whatever uh and it can't be a
uent
8 and actually I think I'm just going to
make it a number pi. uint
32 would be fast
right we're just an n32 I think that'll
be
optimal could make it a 16 I think it's
usually faster to use um four byte types
I could be wrong on
that so now we give it buffer
right and uh now that it takes buffer
so what we're going to do is we just
make a pointer which is just an index so
pointer equal to zero because that's
where we're at right
now uh and we do
buffer
pointer equals zero so we've zeroed out
our initial
right and then what we do
is we're just going to do while
true let's actually make this buffer be
a negative
one make the buffer be negative
1es we can do that
right I don't know if we'll need to or
not but we'll do it
so while
true we're going to
do uh action
equals
buffer
pointer
zero and then what we do is we have
action
drdc don't need to increment the pointer
just
yet okay now we can get our start R our
start C these are these are good
operations these are good
operations this is a good
operation the only operations that we
have that are bad here are this q.
append okay so all we have to do is we
now do buffer of pointer
be slightly more efficient to do pointer
plus equals 1 then buffer of pointer Z
is going to be equal to
zero one two is going to be Dr
action uh I don't know where it got this
three from this is completely wrong but
this is the first update
here like
this and uh this is Dr minus one of
course we mirror this one then we do
pointer plus equals
1 could technically write Loops over
this and it'll be fast
well we might write Loops later I don't
want to have to redo the visualization
stuff by reordering things um so we're
going to do it the stupid way for now
this is
Dr +
one
pointer let's see so the third one it
gave us was Dr C minus one C + one then
we got
Dr see this thing consistently gets [ __ ]
wrong so this is minus one + one for
four minus one + one
and then it is + one + one
right and then it's + one minus
one minus
one I don't even know what it thinks
it's doing at this point but it's minus
one minus
one 1 2 3 4 five six 7 eight Okay so
we will test this to see if this is the
same as
before we
also did we increment the pointer
enough ah wait wait wait wait we screwed
something up here we can't quite do it
this way this is pointer +
one like this we can't increment the
pointer like this cuz we need the
pointer to stay where it
is
okay this is+ three + three +
three bear with
me this is going to be really cool when
it runs like a 100 times faster
okay and then I don't know why I just
did that my brain just decided to stop
working and then finally pointer Plus 8
+ 8 plus
8 boom boom boom and then at the bottom
we increment pointer by one for the next
Loop
this is a reasonable way to break out of
the
loop I would hope
right guess
advance the pointer always needs to
advance by
one so this pointer
increment actually should be up
here and then I need to edit all of
these things
unfortunately
right
y one one one two two two of course it's
way easier to edit them than it is to
add
them okay so that that actually did
run um but I think it did something
weird let's do like
this so it did something
weird
uh let's see what it would have done
+ one wait- one + one right - one + one
plus one +
one so these all are
fine pointer gets incremented
here oh you need two pointers I'm
dumb yep you need two pointers you need
start and end
okay so you need let me explain
this you need to have a start pointer
that tells you where you're consuming
the queue from and an end pointer that
tells you where the Q is done and that's
also going to tell you you're not going
to have to zero the Q out every time so
this is going to be even faster than I
originally intended by quite a bit um
but it does get you do have to keep two
pointers
around so you have start and by pointer
I mean index it's the same thing right
so you do while essentially while
there's still data to consume and then
this is going to get rid of this ugly
break condition
here now this is
End plus equal to 1
and I don't know why it like keeps
giving me these garbage suggestions
okay go work do your thing
damn
right yeah this shouldn't be possible
because I allocated enough space essenti
I allocated enough space for every
single to to go into the
buffer so if this is not working it's
because
[Music]
uh I don't know
me buer start is zero end is
zero you add one to the
start you don't add anything to the end
here
this should be
action wait should this be action or did
I totally screw this thing
up wait
what this isn't action at all I this
thing gives me garbage suggestion
sometimes and it screws me up like I'm
not going to uninstall it because it's
really really nice for the code complete
but the models actually have to get a
little bit better
I wouldn't think this will make a
difference in terms of it not running
though
right yeah it's still going to screww up
if it's going to screw up um
I don't know print start comma end
something that tell me anything remotely
useful tells me the start is keeping up
pretty well with the the start's keeping
up pretty well with this
here cuz I give it grid shape
right and the buffer is n *
N I don't need to subtract one anymore
I'm not using that as a
oh and you should also return
um you should return end as
well wait End plus hold on does this
make sense or am I overwriting
I
think I think it makes more sense to
start this
at
one I do while
start is less than end and then I put
these as postfix Ops
right yeah that'll that'll be nice
because I'm going to want to return the
end that I know how many elements I have
so we'll do return
and
this that's still not going to fix it
why let me see so you get the
action from start right
you get Dr and DC from
start
okay you go start R
here you bounce check
I also don't know why I'm doing it this
way
right
like this Dr and DC doesn't need to be
this
way I can just do this can just be start
R so this should just be like buffer
equal
Z I
guess and then we
do buffer start one equals d
r and then d
c and this is just start R right here
right this is start C so this
simplifies because we don't need this
garbage
anymore yeah because then you just
directly do this is just start
R start r-
one start
C + one start
C start R start C C
-1 start R start C +
one start see almost just did it right
there start our start C+
one
plus
minus minus
one's okay still not going to fix it
makes it cleaner
though now aside from us being able to
roll this into a loop if we um reindex
our actions or reindex the triangles for
drawing so this will be one little Loop
like over
RNC uh maybe we could also just leave it
unrolled like
this
um but aside from that we're pretty much
optimal
oh and the issue is just that the buffer
isn't big enough
right um because you can add the same
tile in multiple times uh you just
can't yeah you can add the same tile in
multiple times you just can't actually
pick the tile multiple times and I think
that the most number of times you can
add a tile in
is hold on it's eight
right so I think it's the buffer
actually got to be pretty freaking big I
think it's 8 time n * n which is you
know a little bit obnoxious
win okay
so you might be wondering why the heck
did I just do all of that
right I just spent a bunch of time to
make the program I'm going to tell you
right now not even any
faster um to refactor it in that exact
weird
manner so the reason that I did
that was that now it's going to be
trivial to scyon
eyes and the way I can tell you that is
I just wrote this thing in a way where
every single operation is going to
effortlessly translate into uh into
purec with no Reliance on python
whatsoever the prerequisites for that
are mainly that you're not using lists
or decks or anything like that or tuples
any python data structures and that all
of your operations can be expressed as
Loops over numpy
arrays and if you do that you're
good
so let's do
um let's have a little fun with this I
think we've earned it
right you want answers I think I'm
entitled
all right so we don't need all this
garbage this is
gorbage get rid of the
gorbage all right and now this is
CNP ND
array
grid can we type
these I think we can I don't know if we
can type
these I don't know if we can type
these we should be able to
right he let's try
it grid CNP ND array paths
CNP Ray buff and we got
int
yeah this is an INT returns an
INT uh we C def int
n and
start kaboom
start now we also have to do of course
these start R start
C
and uh what I like to do is just to
avoid bad variable names is I just like
prefix I postfix these n p n p like this
right
and then what I do is first of all I
don't know why I did this this should
just be a block like this uh so we got
cdef
int cdef int and and int like
this and
then we can see
ah this
is we have to go get the types of these
I think it's
un it's Char for grid
Char grid is grid
NP I think paths is also a
Char and then we used an INT for buffer
like
this
okay
so let's check this
and now what we get to do is we get this
pix import
right and then we do oops
from C precompute import BF as
cbfs
uhhuh and now what we do is we get to
just do
cbfs let's see why why scy why no scyon
I
expected did you use cdef syntax and use
decorators and python type annotations
instead okay so that's slightly awkward
um one of the limitations I think what
if I CP def it does this
scon it is
aized now we'll have to figure out why
it doesn't
buffer
zeros buffer
has only one portion of data in
it and after that is
empty so let's see uh let's see why that
is the case did I get the data types
wrong
we've got paths is a numpy uh
ent8 what did I have Game maps
says game map's the wrong type that
could
out we'll do print
start or was
it start
end
okay one
one well that's not good
paths if grid of start
R start C is equal to
one this is the exact same code as
before is it
not we manag to make the uh this version
work and the other version not work
let's say
yeah so right now the scyon version does
not
match uh the python
version
somewhere it does appear that it is
getting
overwritten it's getting overwritten
somewhere action is equal to
print start R start C
print Paths of start r c print grid
these are the three possible options
right I don't know where else it would
be breaking
negative
one uh that's very
odd what did we give
paths
Char o that's disgusting is it an
unsigned I think it's an unsigned Char
which we shouldn't have to sign it but
okay Char should already be unsigned
there you
go okay gross type bug unsign Char you
got to be
and now let's check the uh do we have an
HTML file in
here we do not have an HTML file so what
we're going to do is we are going to
um we're going to recompile this such
that we get HTML out of
it and then we're going to enable all of
these optimizations
oops so we're going to go up here and
now we're going to tell uh we're going
to instruct cython to compile this with
absolutely no safety features it's not
going to check values for none we're not
doing any division but if we
were actually since we're not doing any
division we can get rid of this one and
we can uh
yeah we can leave these like this
so this is now doing absolutely no
safety checks
whatsoever we're going to add this to
the setup file here and we're going to
turn on this annotation
option and hopefully this should output
us a uh a very
nice
file that will include for us uh a
detailed profile of this code and
anywhere that I've screwed up and is
have made it slow by mistake
of course since I just pulled in all the
changes from this weekend it's
recompiling everything but you know you
win some you lose
some okay so perfect we see we have this
HTML file here recompute pathing
HTML so I have to just because I'm on
WSL I have to move this into
and then if we look at C precompute
pathing
HTML so we can see that this uh function
signature because it's cpde it'll call
back to python no big surprise uh the
initial memory view will call back to
python as well but we are going to have
a way around this when we call this in a
loop so no big deal and then beautiful I
did it perfect on first try uh the fact
that this this is all white and has no
annotations means that this entire
code this is a pure C
call it's a p c call and this is we can
see right here this is just array
indexing so it's just straight up doing
you know array indexing
math which is very very
nice um yeah that's that's
perfect so Let's
uh how fast do you think that these are
versus one another
right what do we
think I have profiling off on this I
believe which is what we
okay so we're going to take this code
right
here
and this will
[Music]
be
grid
R2 you don't need uh you don't need R
you just need c right
one okay
so whoops import time start is time.
time while time. time is less than start
can do
BFS uh it equals z it plus equal
1 see it
zero start time.
time wow
performance and hopefully runs for us
and we will see how much
faster this code
is should take 20
seconds if it takes longer than that
then I will be confused nope there we go
okay perfect so
it divided by
timeout hold on
that so it says the C1 is 10 times
faster which is about right but um I
don't believe that the other one is so
fast I'm worried that it is just doing
the uh the
first right you have to null the grid
every
time yeah you have to know the grid
every time I think or is it the paths or
the grid that you have to know you have
to know the paths every time
paths
255 and the buffer you shouldn't have to
know let's try this again this because
the thing is I wouldn't have bothered
automating it if it were running 145,000
steps per second I wouldn't have
bothered sioning
it that's fast enough that'll like do
the whole thing in a
second but I think you're going to see
that there's going to be a significant
difference yeah that's more like
it so
um yeah that's what we'd
expect is that c number right that seems
really fast
be yeah cuz this is not just C versus
python this is like oh no wait this is
straight up C versus python thousand
times faster that's pushing it isn't
it isn't that pushing
be well I don't want to post this yet
until I'm
positive because whenever you post
something oh it's like 3,000 times
faster or
whatever and then you're wrong you look
really stupid so we're going to let this
uh we're going to work on this for a bit
and if it looks like it is actually that
fast then we're going to go from there
um okay though
so perf test is
set if that is actually the performance
difference though and people are still
writing this type of stuff in Python
like get
hey
Roman
welcome we just made breath first search
really really really
fast here's your breath first search
it's a really
fast is that like ballpark reasonable
though because let me think this is
order of like 10,000 tiles
10,000 time
4,000 oh yeah that's totally reasonable
right it's like tens of millions of St
yeah that's totally reasonable that's
actually very reasonable to expect out
of
C uh the python one being this slow
is also kind of reasonable to be honest
p like Loops end up whenever you're
doing anything with like any logic plus
Loops it goes from tens of millions to
like thous tens of thousands at most
steps per
lot slow
language slow language is
slow uh the nice thing about this is we
should be able to precompute this entire
thing now like Stupid Fast right
yeah we should be able to pre-compute
this whole thing really really stupidly
fast and I haven't even I'm not even
sioning the uh the outer loop
yet so we'll
do this is going to be
cbfs grid paths
RC starting point return paths and we're
going to do uh
paths M Pi
[Music]
Zer isn't it n
recomputed what do you mean how much
faster oh precompute
well I'll tell you how much faster it
goes when it's precomputed it's the
difference between being able to do this
and having it be o of one or having to
do this and having it be like completely
unusable this alone I can tell you this
operation alone if we tried to add this
into our code even if we sconed it it
would limit uh it would limit us to
like well you have it right here
technically let's say we can get this
down a fair bit with uh with
AAR this is only 4,000 Maps computed per
second right so if we're going to say
AAR versus full breath for search is
much more efficient let's say that we
get this down by a factor of 10 so
40,000 steps per second that's still
we're only able to do 40,000 pathfind
searches right per second times like a
couple hundred Minions we're now down to
hundreds of steps per second on our
entire
simulator and I mean maybe you can cach
it and only pre C every so often but
still like we're going to be down to
like maybe thousands of steps per second
on our whole MOA just because of this
one operation compared to what we're
doing right now this is O of one this is
like this is nothing this is
instantaneous so we've basically taken
our path finding from being a bottleneck
that's going to make this entire Sim C
to thousands of steps per second to free
that's what this has
done I don't optimize stuff just for the
sake of op optimizing it most of the
time I optimize stuff when it's going to
make a massive
difference okay so we do pre-compute
path
thing and then
we paths equals this
massive okay so we got our pre-compute
pathing here is a very nice little
function and what are we going to do
with it we're going to call this
function
here and uh I did not mean to do it here
this should have been up here right
so these can go back where they
are we can
pathing uh let's
right and it's grid. shape
don't need any of this we just
pre-computed all the
paths so now what we get to do is uh
render do render we can do pass of R1
and C1 let's see if this
works oh
boy that's not what we wanted
well this is all zeros is what just
happened here
right so it's possible that this was
uh was this a bad
tile hold
well do we need to clear
buffer I don't think so I think I
intentionally designed this we don't
need to clear buffer right
yeah there's zero checks on
Buffer zero checks whatsoever on
Buffer though technically there will be
garbage in at the end of it if we don't
uh well there may there could be garbage
at the end but we actually don't care if
there's garbage at the end the way that
I implemented it so yes this is actually
a very smart
implementation uh the way that this is
done so while why then is this
not
fast that takes a long time time to run
numai unique on this
data well I don't think we're getting
our 4,000 because it's not actually
running appropriately on
it let me see oh we forgot to
do I think we forgot to add to our paths
right plus 255 oh no we're still fine
yeah yeah we're still fine we just
forgot to add it here we're good
very
nice
so this is not an amazing use of time
but I kind of want to do something
fun so we're going to do something fun I
don't think it'll take me very long uh I
want to make this
reactive so where's our right code
here render do
render start R start
C no no no no no we don't do start R
start
C we make it dependent on
the the
mouse uh X
Y hold on for
takes one positional argument but three
were given
this follows me around but the map
doesn't change which I do not
paths this is end
R end C right right the way we did it so
end
C and
R and then this is and
R and
C wait
action
no this is Paths of RC and then what we
do is paths equal self. paths okay there
boom
work invalid index to scalar
variable I do not like invalid index to
scalar
variable Raab Vector field where is this
stupid thing pre-compute pathing paths
ah right here this is you need all the
paths boom
awesome if you go over an obstacle it
just immediately you can't path
there tell me that that isn't like the
easiest ever to make a UI to do like
ridiculous real time this is technically
realtime pathing by the way this is like
this is how fast it would be to like
literally the map is to look up because
it's all
that write of Passage to make your own
realtime pathing demo
it's so cool how it changes as well like
you can see like diagonals and stuff
will change a little bit as you path
around yeah there's a lot of redundant
information here but who cares it
computes like freaking
instantly I wonder if this computes fast
enough for me to
um oh I have an idea we're going to get
this so fast that I don't even have to
ship the file we're going to get this to
be so fast that it's just going to we're
going to make this map on Startup and
it's going to be like .1 seconds or
something to precompute all of these and
you're not going to
notice and that's just how we're going
to demonstrate software
can it be fast enough that you can make
them make them
what path around other creeps and
players
nope not even
close so I think I can see why you would
think that because you say oh look it's
really fast like if you can make all
these maps in less than a second that
surely that's really fast right but like
do you understand how fast the game is
going to be running okay let's say that
I'm going to I'm going to say I'm going
to get a mil a minimum of a million
agent steps per second okay so that is
100,000 uh game steps per second because
they're 10 player so I said 1 million
steps per agent steps per second is
100,000 steps per second that I
currently have the frame rate set to
five I believe it's like five steps per
second so we're going to do over five
that's the number of uh SEC this is the
number of seconds worth of gaml that
we're simulating every second on one CPU
core divide by
3600 means that we are simulating 5 and
a half hours of DOTA per second on one
CPU Cor that is how fast this thing is
going to have to
run I like to do that once in a while
because you know when the performance
numbers get to be ridiculous you can
just keep saying bigger and bigger
numbers and everybody will just say oh
yeah well that's pretty fast but then
when you say no no no no I'm simulating
five and a half hours of DOTA per second
on one CPU core then you get it right
cool what did I want to do with this
there was something else I want to do
right I wanted to save a gift of this
so when I put it that way it makes it
makes sense right like the thing I'm
building it it's way way cooler when you
understand that is the level of
performance that I'm going for right
like games are not made to be this fast
like games are made to run real time or
maybe 10 times real time so that it runs
on like low-end Hardware
right this
is here where is
it actually we know right here just by
this division by five this is made to
run
20,000 times real
time that's what we
want it's going to take some performance
engineering to get there but that's what
we're going for here 20,000 times real
time I like performance
engineering it's very performant
cool we can put the loop in
scon this is going to be a this is going
to be a CP no this is going to be a defa
that takes a grid this is going to be a
CDE meaning it runs
100% in
scon this is going to be
I think we do want to
um I think this will be a CP def so that
we can type it like this CNP NP
grid because we're going to do c
death like
this okay and then we have passed
in these memory
views which are now going to
be grid
NP I think we can just do like this
unsigned
Char and then we can do unsign
Char they totally screwed up my
indexing so I'll type it manually
paths
okay and uh
good grid paths buffer o
call and uh
RNC oh in RNC
we get rid of all of this
gorbage
dep like so
right and uh you know now we get
um Rec compute pathing
here
so we can do import we can't import this
anymore we can do pre-compute pathing
as C import as C precompute
pathing and now this is just breath for
search
right and this will be even better for
timing though I don't even know if this
is going to be reasonable to time
because I think that the python version
will be too slow to
run isn't that
funny but yeah so we're going to
do c precompute pathing
pathing right we uh get rid of these
numpy variables these are now typed
correctly
as
unsigned
Char View
grid uh this is unsigned Char
paths in
buffer
NP
and this one says cbfs where it should
just be BFS because we are in
C and what else
paths cannot convert unsigned Char to
memory view
slice well that's because this is just
stupid and we have to Index this way
pathing pre-compute pathing from C
precompute
pathing this has to be a CP dep
look at that so we have our same code
working as before let us time the
function how fast is this is this fast
enough for us to do stuff
with we
compute or do we have to cach it we
might still have to cach it
data 3 seconds so we're going to want to
cach
it but 3 seconds
it's pretty
good 3 seconds is pretty
good uh let us let's make a gift out of
this for the
Twitter this is some performance
engineering so actually based on that
we'll be able to tell if uh this was
correct because this is what did we say
python 128 *
128 no wait yeah this is the number of
maps uh divide by three oh it's even
faster now it's 5400 steps per
second because I automated the outer
loop right so we're no longer remaking
the data
constantly that's pretty darn good
so like
3,000 like 3,000 times faster than
python what about this paths colon
equals oh yeah yeah we don't need that
in the main test we're good we are
good and how much data did we say this
was cuz I saved it as a Char
right so it's it's a 128 * 128 * 128 *
MB 268
megabytes that's ridiculous
uh 268 megabytes of pathing data
calculated and generated in 3
seconds I'm liking this performance
engineering thing I'm liking it
this let's set the fps to 30
maybe now that's still going to be way
too much data at this
resolution uh we'll set the fps to
[Music]
it okay we'll set the fps to 15 on
this and we'll do
frames frames equals like
this before I in range
6 seconds of data is
90 90
frames
frame frames.
append and then we'll
uh
recompute or let's just do pathing dog
so I don't overwrite anything by mistake
looks and lots of cool stuff
here lots of cool
stuff oh yeah that's a great gift six 6
MB
perfect we'll do
uh one more try I want get something
real cool looking
up try not to hit the
edges got to not hit the
edges right
I thought I just fixed
it is this not the right
smaller I think I can just make the font
smaller right so I can put it in a
it's not going to be readable in a
screenshot if I do this will
it we'll do it
anyways Miss as
well
oops let's
do star p ER
that seems will has gotten bored and has
stopped streaming meaning that I win for
the
[Music]
day okay well this is
awesome um I'm very happy with this
result this didn't even take that long
right this took what four hours four
hours of streaming is that how long
we've been
live from
scratch so we're going to get to
integrate this now with the mooba
obviously
um I'm going to take a couple minutes
going to go use the restro real quick
going
to uh make a shake and then we're going
to integrate this with the MOBA
and we're basically just going to have
massively overpowered pathing and uh we
can actually have highle commands now
like we can write a function that's just
like you know path to or like you know
move towards and it can be anywhere on
the map and that function is now o of
one and we don't even need to like save
like you know destinations along the way
or anything for it it's just it'll just
do it now so that's real cool
anyways I'll be right back
and uh I don't know go like this if you
want to help with the promo and Star
Puffer if you haven't helps me out a ton
be right
back anybody ask where I am tell them
I'll be back in a
I don't know if you're still there if so
how do you like
this oh of one pathing for the entire
game
this is what it's going to take to fix
reinforcement learning we need
simulators that care this much about
perf if we don't have
perk
RL is just going to be
slow and you're going to have to be
Google in order to do
it if we have
simulators that can be as complex as
like you know I don't know strip down
DOTA this is the goal here that actually
really care about
performance and you can never be
bottlenecked by
them then we're looking pretty good then
we're looking really really
good so
we're going to integrate
this now we're going to integrate
this we might even make some scripted AI
because why not right we can basically
now reuse the creep AI for the heroes
and we can have them just run at each
other
um and then we'll see from there I'm
probably to spend three-ish hours on
this right
now so let's get the pathing integrated
first uh so that we actually get this in
the main
game I think we are going to cash it as
well but we're not going to we're not
going to distribute a 200 megabyte file
what we're going to do is we're just
going to cash it on start up right we're
just going to cash it on
Startup okay let's fix the these uh what
is this this tiny font I think it was
16 oh jeez this now needs to be the
correct size
boom okay
well so you guys can actually have this
if you want it
what the
heck oh the follow buttons are leaking
from over here that's fine just
wondering the stream looked
from
H see
wonky Rec compute pathing I think we had
to modify it
here what the heck where's the call oh
right there um game
map pathing map equals we'll just we'll
do it this way for now game map. copy
pathing
map0 is equal to one and pathing map
equal to 255 is equal to
Z we'll leave it like that for
now and now we do pre-compute
pathing and this is going to return pre
compute returns paths
so
this self. AIP
paths and actually what we're going to
do is we're going to do
um
pathing
cash
numpy
okay
try
accept
here
a self. AIP paths right
have you know these things on them as
well this should be
CNP should all be
typed it's just like asking for bugs in
scon not to type
them scon doesn't always interpret stuff
right if you don't explicitly type it
and unlike you know most compiled
languages uh it will actually not typing
it will cause runtime
errors
so now we do self. AIP paths and where
did we do this completely got it wrong
it's 4D like
interesting
engage
so we need to just make a method path
towards
right is how it's going to
WS okay so it's going to be
entity destination and we need a float
speed
right
yeah this is
good and do we want to give it the
integer here
I think we want to give it int dest y
int d x because if you already have it
computed you don't want to redo the
cast
so shouldn't be that
hard int
um
entity YX
oh clip to Nega one and
one it's kind of
self. AIP
pass that's exactly what we
want
okay DX
Dy and now we have to do this uh
obnoxious thing so if action equals z
and we will
um we have to flip all of these which is
the obnoxious
portion because this is this is how you
go away from the destination so we have
to flip
them so if action is equal to
zero then we
do
d y =
1 if action is
one then we do Dy is
1 then DX is 1 DX is 1 and let's
see so this
is was it it's goes minus and then plus
so we have to do plus and then
minus and then it goes plus and then
plus so we have to do minus and then
minus
right and then we do for
seven uh we missed one of these
somewhere so that's not good let me see
three so four is uh we missed one with
four so this
is
plus and then minus right and then this
is plus and
plus and this is
minus
and
plus minus and
plus and
then plus and plus and we did something
backwards
because I see five here that I have plus
and plus this one's supposed to be minus
and minus let me double check these
because it's very important that I have
these
correct they should be all flipped from
The
Originals so this plus and plus goes
minus and minus this minus and plus goes
plus and then
minus this one is minus c plus c
yeah so I have all these
correct okay so now what we do
is entity dox entity
doy um actually we need this move two
right so we
do float
dust y float dust
dust
y d
x and then we
do move two I
think how do you deal with eye fatigue
from looking at this monitor for long
periods of
time oh jeez um
I've been doing this for so long that I
no longer get eye fatigue from uh
looking at a screen I get eye fatigue
from going
outside so basically even if it's
partially cloudy if I'm outside I'm
wearing sunglasses
things does this thing take into account
move
I think this is good though
right and then we
do we can make this a beant as well
right and we can
return move
to that's really
nice so now with this creep path thing
right we can replace this whole thing
with uh
if grid
dis is not
and I think this is fine so what we do
is we do move
Dy wait creep
path can we just replace this whole
function I think we can replace this
whole
function I think I can just go like this
right and then I can just
do
um yeah literally this right but I do
need this
Clause This is the End way point right
[ __ ] AI
paths death why these are both in buddy
what's wrong with
you invalid in index Type
looat move
towards am I
me hold on is it
maybe no this is self agent speed right
you call it with creep agent speed into
of dust Y into dust X did I redefine the
variable somehow
no uh that's freaking weird is there
another bug up here oh yeah there bugs
up here that's
why uh clear nope not that one
clear and
build and we still have the bugs up here
float dust y yep
redeclared as
expected that breaks
[ __ ] um d y is going to
be entity doy wait entity
y Dy times speed this is totally
good it's totally
good what other bugs we
got cannot assign type float to
int uh yeah so we're going to just on
line This Then entity
doy
y plus Dy *
speed okay we're going to just like
this that's
nice obviously we got to delete these
guys
on no we're
good free invalid neck
really do I have to
do I have all the checks
on
right do we have anything in here that
tells us
anything invalid next
size normal
these things have type checks on them
don't they these memory views
I would have thought that these would
have d
y we're going to do this and we're going
to see if we get any values that are
like wonk
so I mean if we're not getting any of
these is this thing aboring even if I
just do it like this like what what's
going on here right
okay so it's AB boarding this even
though um we haven't changed the
freaking code so let's go figure
out I'm sure that there's some weird
Jank thing in here
right compute
path it's possible this is looping or
some dumb [ __ ] is
happening let's see
no file po Li environments ocean M
pathing okay that's fine
right
accept gam map. copy set
don't okay let's see what the hell
happened um apparently our our
pre-computation code was working fine
before but it was not working
here game map.
shape the 128
oops it is a 128 by 128 game
MTH game map I should say
128 by
unate ah well that would be that well
there's your problem
pathing
okay there we
go here's our game we can play it yada
yada
GP now what we're going to do is we're
going to try to change some
[ __ ]
boards all right and now move towards is
going to be like this this
this nope stop freaking giving me bad
suggestions
autocomplete and
layer build
here very weird that this paths to there
like this
that the neutrals are also pathing
weird is it possible that the pathing
directions are
wrong and never see them turning which
is
weird this one right here you'd expect
to turn
this let me
see why is this one going this way
it's possible I just have the actions
all flipped
right will these two
go totally wrong direction
okay where do we update the waypoints
here if found Target
else creep
path L2
Waypoint
move creep agent speed so we have
move
towards wrong
order dest y dest x X andd Y ntid
X there we
go so now let's see decent chance we get
something more
reasonable ever heard of probabilistic
programming it refers to the probability
that your program works the way you
intend it to
okay oh look at
that look at this snake action
here look at that that's sweet so
they're getting stuck on Towers because
um towers are not included on the base
map but look at this like that's some
really freaking cool movement
right Hy they and then like
perfectly it's a little funny that they
perfectly jump bump into each other so
we're going to probably want to Jitter
it a little
that okay
um
Towers Tower positions
let's add some Jitter and then we'll do
Tower
alive do I not have a Jitter in
here this thing here
maybe
float
X Lo Jitter
y times
speed do you do two times speed
I don't think you need these spaces here
either no you like these spaces these
are good perceptually grouped so agent
speed oh no but the it should be the the
two should be grouped here right because
it's two times thing
minus5 yeah so this is the perceptual
this is how it should be grouped and
then what we do is we
do Jitter at y
guess let's see what that Jitter does
agent speed what
the I love it when it makes up variables
that are just not in my freaking code my
favorite thing man
and I think I wanted to do this first
right we can do
this let's do it that way that way we
have a modified by speed because
otherwise it's going to be
boom we had a little to the movement
which to be fair I'd prefer not to have
to
do oh yeah that's way
better look at that they go right around
the
it uh the neutral creeps are behaving a
little weird there's too much Jitter
right
cool I like look at the snaking Mo
motion like it when it rounds this
corner is pretty
cool these neutrals are yeah this is too
much so this is too much
Jitter let's
do we'll cut it in half
I'm incredibly happy with
that so like the thing
is yes they could do that before
technically but before they were using a
series of uh way points and they were
just going straight line path from one
Waypoint to the
next whereas
now we have arbitrary path finding that
can go around
obstacles what are they getting stuck on
here what the heck are these guys oh
they're stuck on the
tower this guy shouldn't be stuck though
what like what is this guy stuck on here
I think he's stuck on being
stupid maybe the Jitter what
couldn't be
stuck well maybe we will uh we'll add
the towers
where's the tower
positions oh yeah here this
this and we we open a file don't
we yaml
here yeah there's yaml
uh it prefix tier
suffix entity data Tower name y
this do we set this to one or
zero we'll just try
both and
okay so now we're just going to put the
Tower data into the the
map yeah so now I can't tell for sure if
they get stuck or not this guy looks
like yeah they look like they're still
getting stuck let's remove the Jitter
just so we can tell for
sure Jitter
this now let's
see I think it's possible that I just
have the sign
flipped does it work
nope so we can see here clearly that
they get stuck on the
towers kind of weird that they stop this
far away as
well let's just do
um this pathing map is going to be zero
now pathing cash
numpy okay so now it'll have to
precompute
it they should not be able to get stuck
on their own Towers
anymore which is clearly what's
happening right
here they can't be stuck on each other
right no they can't that's not how the
game engine
works this looks this portion here looks
good but something's stuck
this let's see what is in the m in the
map currently I want to just make sure
we're correctly we're flipping this on
so it's zero so we were correct the
first time it should be one which is
what I
is it possible that the way that I'm
Computing pathing things can still get
stuck if they don't move fast
enough if groups of Agents don't move
for some seconds
penalize that will not happen with more
training there's no mode so this is not
a training thing this
is I think what is happening is that
when I compute the path Maps right I'm
Computing the path uh the optimal
pathing
assuming that agents
move uh one unit per
second but the thing is if they move
less than one unit per
second then
like they could still get stuck on stuff
right so let's say that the optimal path
is like you come up to a corner and you
want to move diagonally around the
corner right if you don't move fast
enough you're going to get stuck on the
corner that's a thing that can happen
right yeah so let me let me explain this
for the chat
here is this the bad one yeah this is
the garbage one I don't know why this
freaking app exists this one's so dog
[ __ ] um is this
good yeah this one's
fine so
you have a tile here like
this
right and let's say that I'm starting
here this is your
obstacle and your destination tile is
here okay so the way that the pathf
finding gets
computed it gets computed using uh L1
distance no l Infinity distance y
Infinity so the way the pathing works is
it looks here it looks you know over
here it looks here and it looks for you
know a way around this obstacle so let's
say it finds this one it says look if I
just take one step to the diagonal then
I get to this
tile but what happens if your agent
isn't that fast right
your agent let's say that they move
half um or let's say that they get like
partially into a tile right so it could
happen that your agent gets to like
right here and then it does the check
and then it tries to move this way but
it actually can only move this far so it
gets stuck into this
tile because it can't clip across the
corner
problem this Tower patch is going to be
better than
nothing we're going to regenerate the uh
the map pathing data one more
time and then uh we're going to we're
going to add just a little bit of
Jitter and we're going to hope this is
good we got to tune the Jitter amount
just a little bit because I don't want
it to be too
much I think that there should only be a
little bit of Jitter just enough to
break up the symmetries and
stuff we also might want to pre-compute
the Jitter which would be
funny I'm literally like looking at that
Rand function as oh the Rand function
could be too
slow okay well this is
weird now this I don't know what they're
getting stuck
on I think we should load this up in
human
mode and go watch
them oops let's get this out of the way
so it's not obscuring
chat uh pathing map is not associated
with
a
whoops no wait it's right there yep
right there
human huh oh this is just the mouse
cursor bug that's fine hold
on okay so we have some
tile so these guys should not be stuck
here
right I think they're stuck on each
other
maybe did I like lose the check to make
sure that they don't get stuck on each
other
this path finding here is pretty
good
boom no leave me
[Music]
alone we will go in for a
kill
yeah heroically
so they're stuck on something let's see
uh I might have messed up some
logic so what did I do with this creep
pathing logic
right ah it's this thing right here I
believe
to
if but this looks good right here
because I have this logic wait
one so float Jitter
X and Float Jitter y this can go in here
right if grid
y looat move
to
Y
in let's just let's make it work and
then we'll make it nice
so move to
Y and get rid of
Jitter
okay and then what we're going to going
to
do is we're going to
return move
to Jitter X Jitter
y two
times speed
two *
is move
to hold
on
entity
um
entity. y plus what the [ __ ] are these
suggestions
X okay so we return move two
otherwise return plus speed no Jitter
maybe maybe no Jitter maybe we determin
ASE for now
pathing is not easy good pathing good
like creep
AI not
easy possible inconsistent
I yeah let's just go go like
this let's
go how my
puffers where my puffers
at well they're not
stuck they pass through this way more
cleanly now
right render mode is going to
be rib
this looks way better
right a
pathing I'd say that's
clean occasionally one of them can
glitch we're going to increase the
Jitter we can actually this is the nice
thing is
um I think we just
do we don't do two times speed we just
we just straight up Jitter them one tile
this is a one tile
Jitter that is a lot more aggressive but
the thing is we only do it when they're
stuck so if we only Jitter them when
they're
stuck that'll be better
it might be a bit much we'll see I got
to check what the default move speeds
are I think it's like 0.
five I mean
that's that's like perfect
though
right and like look at the fight like
the Frontiers on the fights I just want
to point this out like look how clean
these Frontiers are like you get like
these act like organic looking battles
cuz they like or they just like Jitter
until they find a spot that they can
fight like the nearest
one and like you get this like snake
like pathing around all the way
points these are the actual DOTA way
points as
solid now now the neutral
creeps we're probably going to let them
just chill out
because they're like spazzing they
should kind of just be chilling in place
for the most
oh they're allowed to spaz out randomly
it's just gotten lucky that's
fine yeah these ones like they are way
less locked in oh my gosh do you see
this Tower this red one is pulling this
Tower around do you see
this this red one just pulled the tower
all the way they freaking pulled the
tower they pulled the tower through the
wall as well they deleted the wall with
the tower
okay guys I told you I would leave this
in as an Easter egg but like are we
crazy that they're just like this is
them acting randomly imagine that they
actually play this and they just learn
to pull all of their towers to right
around the Nexus and just sit there
like what what are you going to do
you're getting hit by freaking nine
[Laughter]
[Music]
Towers just becomes a game about pulling
the enemy's
Towers okay we got to kill this before
it kills us with the
how's the Twitter have we have we gotten
a million a million billion
likes oh he's still
alive had to take a break I
say that's no
happy to say we uh we broke 4k on the
account so the growth has just been
awesome and if I recall puffer lib is um
oh shoot we got
661 this is
awesome right here this is just
great I really hope we can keep this up
this pace of growth is just great for
the
project yeah I hope
so like the the uh I think that the one
that will potentially do very well is
the the one that I already posted you're
not going to be able to tell the pathing
difference just looking at the Moa
without looking very closely
it's the key thing is the new pathing is
just going to make everything less
glitchy and bad so before
let's say that you lur a
creep if you lur a creep somewhere
random it basically would just be stuck
now it will actually correctly path back
to Lane like in the real
game because it has perfect pathing from
anywhere on the map with the one
exception being that if it gets uh there
like there's weird discretization stuff
where it can get stuck on an obstacle
but then it'll Jitter out and it'll
continue its path so it's pretty
efficient
either
funny
okay let's
try let's try some stuff out
so we should be able to simplify and
clean up a lot of the uh the NPC logic
with this and possibly even add like
some basic scripted player control to
this and definitely we should be able to
improve the human player control uh with
this as
well
so it's 5:00
p.m. I think we can be a little more
ambitious than just that right
let's start with
this so first of all this creep path
okay what we do move
towards is what we
did okay move
towards and do we have float dest y we
do
uh agent
speed be
fine and then this is
also move
towards
this so let's try this to start
right uh we also we forgot that we need
this in the neutral NPCs as well move
fors
so right
here if found
L2 so we're basically always going to do
a distance calc right so we can just
float
dist no we can't because it's a
different
L2
does less than
two then you path towards your spawn if
you're like not close enough to it it
right and then we delete creep path
which is a nice big block of code to be
able to delete I'm happy with
that which puts us now at 11:47
lines let's
see I think we just confused some
variables it's that time of day
again very happy with the progress I've
been putting and I'm not actually all
that happy with my hours though I would
like to be putting in more hours I know
I've been getting tired
fast uh what the heck this shouldn't be
creep path this should be move
towards right agent
speed yeah this should be
this into d
y move
towards this says Target
perfect these creeps are stationary they
should be
stationary now the question is if we do
render mode human and we screw with a
couple of them if they're still
stationary here we go here's our MOA
going to boost on
over and we're going to say hi to the
neutral
creeps the neutral creeps are kind of
hidden in this terrain we can fix
that ah no they're
attacking and if they stop attacking do
they path back to their
target okay so they get stuck let me
just double check that they don't have
two
okay they get stuck at the moment let's
figure out why that
is scan
AOE exclude
hostile do you intend to let neutral
creeps be pulled into Lane creeps oh
[ __ ] I forgot is that a thing in Dota
did the lane creeps fight the neutrals
in DotA
pulling yeah yeah it's been so long
since I've played man I haven't played
since like open AI 5 days done on
radiant bottomer yeah okay I used to
play
um P4 Lena which tells you that I have
no idea what the hell I'm
doing
um let me
think yeah I remember you would pull the
camps you could stack the camps there's
a lot of [ __ ] you could do right
it's interesting I'd be open to
it not the first thing I'm going to
implement
but neutrals near Mid look very close to
the Lane could work out on all Lanes
they shouldn't be any closer than they
would be
normally I guess the map is slightly
downscaled so the character model should
maybe be
smaller um but this is the exact DOTA
map
like so here's the DOTA map right this
is exactly where all the obstacles are
on the real DOTA map just
downscaled everything should be one to
one the same with
that let me figure out what the heck is
happening here first because this is
higher priority uh I think what I was
going to do is I was kind of just G to
code you know a whatever the heck I can
do with the MOBA to make it interesting
and then get some kind of cool RL models
on it that was going to be the highest
priority thing and then if people like
this project if this project gets enough
attention then what I will do is I'll
open it up to some DOTA players and say
like hey you know what are some of like
the most important things about DOTA
that I'm missing here that you know
maybe I could easily add a few modif
ifications right
awesome project by the way I was
watching videos on YouTube first time
ACR the stream what map version of are
you're using I think it's really old I
think it's like 7.3 or something I can
update it very easily as the thing I
just need the data files in like a
reasonable format so I found some repo
online that had already like scraped all
the tower positions and scraped the
neutral positions and like the map data
and stuff so I'm using that I only found
one from like 7.3 or something like that
um I have no idea how much it's changed
over the years no
idea like I'm sure it's changed in ways
that DOTA players find like yeah they
make huge differences on the game playay
but like visually if you were to look at
the map then and look at the map now are
you immediately going to go oh that's
totally different or is it like at a
high level the same
thing like I know League redid the like
they redid the way that the jungle
worked I don't know last year and it was
like a huge thing for the way that the
game plays but for anybody who doesn't
play league like you look at the map
before you look at the map after and
it's like the same
Target found Target equal scan AOE if
found
Target nearest scanned but basic
otherwise move
towards L
if spawn y spawn X less than two move
towards neutral spawn y neutral spawn
X why is this not
[Music]
valid do they spawn inside of uh
uh do they like spawn inside of um
terrain or something hold on maybe this
is just like a bad spawn I don't
know and not really live Human
mode but yeah the goal is not to spend
forever on this project right like I
want to do a whole bunch of cool stuff
on stream I don't want to get stuck on
this forever come on
puffer yeah yeah you know you want to
follow me ha what are you going to do
you're going to stay there and be
stuck get blink stried on I don't know
why this blink strike drains my Mana
like that without teleporting me uh we
got stuff to fix but so it just doesn't
freaking follow
me L2 distance of neutral. Y neutral
dox if found
distance you're going to basic attack
otherwise you're going to move towards
me L
if what the
hell why is this
not why does this not do
it neutral that spawn one
y neutral. spawn
I don't know if you've seen them as well
uh I guess I really need to upload the
uh the snake Dev streams to X cuz that
was the first week I built like this
4096 player snake game in a week that
runs at 14 million steps per second
single
core that was like an easier to follow
stream as
well cuz that environment is like way
simpler than
this way
simpler okay puffers pull the puffers
come on
puffer you know you want to follow
me okay so now he just moving towards a
whole bunch
right and now he's no longer moving
towards oh no he is still moving towards
what the heck
do you have a g good resource to learn
ml wanted to make a game similar to
Total
War and make an AI for
that you're jumping in at the deep end
so I've worked in natural language
processing vision and reinforcement
learning uh reinforcement learning is by
by far the hardest because in addition
to the things that you need to learn
with ML you need a substantial bit of
engineering to deal with the simulation
stack right not to mention we have a
bunch of very cursed things as well
though I'm working on that um ml in
general cs231n lectures online either
Andre or
Justin's probably the best place to
start reinforcement learning from there
the fundamentals aren't all that
complicated if you get ml little bit of
math not too much the main thing is just
ridiculous quantities of engineering
you know I spent four hours today
pre-computing pathing I don't know if
you were here for this um I spent four
hours today pre-computing
pathing uh this is 268 megabytes of
pathing data and as a result the
simulator can now do pathing while
running like a thousand times faster
than it would otherwise um like this is
the level of stuff that it takes to get
really high performance Sims that are
going to be usable with reinforcement
learning um I mean that said it is just
getting easier and easier and the
approach that I've been taking with uh
snake and with this project and with all
the other Sims I've been developing is
one that I would say is fairly
accessible um it's it's something that
you can pick up for sure uh it will take
some work it will definitely take some
work fundamentals though start with 231n
go from there
RL there's I forgot that uh it's kind of
dated but for RL there's open AI
spinning up
documents it's way more math than you
need and the code isn't great still
probably one of the better
resources you can also just read through
clean RL clean RL is awesome
I think I might just not have been
paying
attention no it say moving towards
[Music]
already right
because oh
stupid stupid
stupid there we go
man I got to not be recking messing up
my code bases towards the end of the day
because I just like Miss stuff like
that all right puffers what do you got
you got
game H you got nothing that's right you
go back to the hole here we're going to
lure a puffer hey puffer what are you
doing what are you doing you're doing
nothing go
Eed
cool isn't
map it'd be better if they went on top
of the map if they were going to clip
like this
right PR computed pathing is very cool
does it rule out any Dynamic Mac changes
Co though like collision with other nope
you can still collide with other
entities you just can't account for them
in pathf finding um which you wouldn't
be doing anyways
pdubs the difference
in the difference in computational
efficiency though with doing it this way
versus like trying to do AAR in in the
loop it's like a difference of like
Factor 10,000 or something
so yeah it's
massive stuff like this is what's going
to let this run a million steps per
second
pdubs is the original author of the uh
the viral Pokemon Red reinforcement
learning
project been helping out with that with
puffer mostly just sponsoring compute
these days but uh awesome awesome
project go check it out if you haven't
already Okay so this now works
um what was wrong with my renderer again
oh right I forgot I still was using the
old renderer for the
grid that's obnoxious
um we're probably going to swap this out
anyways
this will do it right this fixes
it
whoops hey
bebs
welcome uh tile is zero or two
continue and then I forgot to just
Define this here
right and we're just going to hack this
because I'm going to replace this client
any I wrote a better client
this will just make it cleaner for the
time being cuz now when you do when you
do weird stuff um yeah you'll go on top
or you'll you'll go through the map when
you
do so like if I boost towards this you
can boost through it just depends on
your
speed and then you can actually see the
targets oh
no what's the data format for
pre-computed path how are they looked up
it is a 268 megabyte 4D table you index
it with um destination y comma
destination X because
assumedly that's the thing that's
changing the least often so for cache
coherency those go first and then um
your current y your current X so simple
4 DET table lookup
takes 3 seconds to pre-compute those um
268 megabytes of data by the way the
scon implementation for pre-computation
is 3 seconds uh that's about 3,000 times
slower than the python Implement 3,000
times faster than the python
implementation so the python
implementation would literally take
hours to run
so ionized it both because it would be
cool it would you know save me time
ultimately not having to wait for the
thing and also I don't have to
distribute a 260 whatever megabyte
file right I just cach it the first time
you make the environment so you only get
3 second startup once and after that you
have much faster
startup okay so this is good now we made
the render a little
prettier um technically we could get a
nice background for
this if we wanted to we could paint like
a cool background for
this I don't want to use the DOTA map I
think that
that like using DOTA data for a science
project that's one thing using their
artwork that's kind of sketch so we're
not going to do that
unless they tell me I
can 5:30 wasn't that bad let me think
what else we can do for tonight let me
think of something
cool how many paths is that in total
well it's from every tile on a 128 by
128 map to every other
path right on the
map so
behind each index is a full path no it's
no behind each index is the movement
that you should take right so if you're
if you want to get to d y comma d x and
you're currently at start y comma start
X what move do you take and then you do
the next lookup with your new start
position and you get your next move so
that's 200 128 to the 4th IS 268
million we're storing it each uh each
action is one bite so that gives you 268
MB also had you seen pre-computed path
used in other projects or is this just
what made sense to you this is just what
made sense to me I haven't seen people
do
this I mean maybe there probably some
projects that do it but I'd assume it's
pretty
rare I mean like
If This Were when you implement this
efficiently like you could do this
probably 10,000 plus times per second if
you wanted to and you don't ever have to
like update the paths that often so you
could have a game with a thousand
players doing this in a real time
without pre-computation no problem but
the thing is that
um this game is going to run at 20,000
times real time per core 128 squared um
um no not really it it depends what you
mean by how many paths are there
like the number of paths is technically
from any node to any other node on the
graph right so the number of nodes is
equal to 128 squared and then the number
of paths is 128 squar squared so they're
128 to the 4th different possible
paths and they're stored in 128 to 4
bites because um the paths all overlap
so you can you know you don't have to
store the individual path that way
otherwise it would be ridiculous you
wouldn't be able to store it if you
stored the individual paths like that
without overlap and it wouldn't even be
any
faster I think the chat is pretty
delayed uh let me see edit
settings we have stream settings for
YouTube is there like a stream hold on
let me do this off
screen uh
[Music]
settings
playback and
settings playback and performance is there streaming are there
performance is there streaming are there
like streaming like laty things on
YouTube I seem to remember there
being streaming latency
settings I'll mess with this later
because I don't think I can do it while
keeping the stream
up I think it's like 10 or 15 seconds I
didn't notice the last one for a bit
um but yeah when you see my when you see
your message pop up on my screen that's
when I can see it it shouldn't be 40
seconds that's
ridiculous if it is that's YouTube being
Jank but basically as soon as you see
your message pop up on the actual stream
um message there I can see it if I were
to open the YouTube chat window I'd be
able to see him
instantly I don't have that open though
I just have the uh the plugin it's only
delayed about 5 Seconds okay okay yeah I
don't know
then okay next stuff with the Moa um
there was so much stuff I wanted to do
with this project but I want to figure
out like what are the key key things we
need because I'd like to have models
training on this relatively
soon message is taking like a minute to
show up in the Stream after that's weird
then I don't know uh it can be endpoint
specific I don't know if you're on
mobile or
weird I haven't changed anything in my
settings as far as I'm
aware oh it's my fault I was watching
the video a minute
behind
LOL that's
um stuff to do on this project
now there's some game balance stuff that
we have to
do there is a little bit of debugging
stuff that we have to do with specific
skills uh it would be cool to get like
some sort of Baseline type
thing like can we just have the what if
we just like make the agents run at each
other down mid or like run at each other
down a specific
aisle so are there multiple heroes yes
we have five different
Heroes we don't have like 20 Heroes but
we have
five I'll show you
them we've got uh we've got a support
character that has a hook a hook pull an
AOE heal and a uh single Target stun I
believe we've got an assassin character
that's the one that I've been playing
that has uh an AOE that can only target
creeps they have a blink strike so they
can teleport and hit and then they have
a channeled movement buff tox move speed
there is the mid character that's
supposed to be bursty so they've got a
single Target nuke they've got uh a
pretty strong AOE and they also have an
AOE
stun basically modeled this off of
Lena and then we've got uh there's a
tank that has an AOE damage over time a
strong self heal as well as an engage
AOE and then there is a uh a
carry the carry or the bottom whatever
has a a retreat slow a spell that they
can use on an enemy to push themselves
back and slow that enemy down uh this
was modeled off of like Caitlyn's net if
you know that there is a a slowing
damage so you can use it to poke Dam
poke and also slow the target you can
use it to like cut them off from
retreating lots of things and then they
also have an AOE to help them uh farming
minions can other Heroes see what heroes
are with the purpose to know their
strength or weakness that will be
implemented I haven't implemented it yet
I just need to have different Graphics
basically uh I need to like make
different character Graphics or
something I don't know maybe I should
just like export a 2d of the puffer
swimming or something that'd be a fun
that'd be fun for movement
I think what we're going to do for today
because it would be
fun um let's try to just
like hack the creep AI to make it work
with the
heroes right so we can have the heroes
run at each other down you know three
different Lanes or whatever
and uh then we can run the game really
really fast and we can see if like
anybody actually takes all the towers
right and we can get some like some cool
graphs or some cool stats on like levels
and stuff like that I think that would
be a cool thing to
do yeah because then the thing is once
we know that then we can like start
tuning stuff around that and uh then we
can start doing like a little bit of RS
stuff around this cuz I definitely I
don't I want to have uh I want to start
working on the neuronet side of this no
later than Wednesday so we can start
getting experiments
running because it's going to take a
little bit of
work how did you learn coding I'm in uni
first year and it's so hard to code any
advice takes a long time to get
good um I started programming
I guess we'll say seriously at like age
16 or 15 but really more like
so 13 14 years by
now
um I've been doing research for most of
that amount of
time I've been doing like software heavy
side stuff in research for most of that
time I've always had like tons of side
projects and other things that I've been
working
on and it really really pisses me off
when I write bad code which is the ma
the biggest
thing I make a few exceptions for this
stream so I can get stuff done fast but
then I always go back and refactor
stuff these skills aren't
bad just create a class be able to add
edit remove a class
yeah little games are
fun you can try to implement like a
basic snake game or
whatever that's like a you can do that
in 200 lines of code
let me think what we're going to do
here so I want to hack
this creep
AI what happens if I just call creep
AI on the heroes can I just do that
that I think I can
right just call creep AI on the
heroes and have them not use their
skills
yet I think I literally can do that hold
on let me
um let me apply the lanes and stuff to
things
uh I have to go copy I don't I just need
to see this for a moment
okay
so all I have to do
is
uh self. get
entity player uh
of
player
zero yeah
dot
Lane this is lane two I
think creep. Lane where do we set the
lanes
here yeah that's where so lane two is
the bottom Lane so we're going to set
support and
both supports go to the bottom
Lane oh no wait that's that's
wrong this is
five get entity one lane
is the Assassin
is oh yeah this is supposed to be a
roaming
character I actually don't know where to
send this Ro roing character so I'm just
going to send it to the Top Lane for now
cuz I didn't account for that like it's
going to have to learn how to do other
stuff get entity two this is the mid
character this is going to go
which is
two
okay so and then we're going to do self
get
entity
five it's going to be sent to Lane the
bottom Lane which is uh
five get ntity six is going to be sent
to the Top Lane which is
three and D7 is going to be sent to the
uh mid lane which is
four get entity
8 is going to be sent to
the uh bottom Lane as well which is
five get entity 9 is going to be sent to
the a Top Lane which is three and self.
get entity 10 is going to be sent to
the bottom Lane which is five
okay remove all this I was just using it
as a
reference we need to move this down
one like
do is we're going to do the creep AI on
the
players so player logic right
here is going to
be okay so they they have this for their
skills I
guess um let's just let's just comment
these three
lines
creep creep
yeah I wonder what this does I wonder if
this
works render
mode Li
stuck okay very weird that this one is
stuck but
overall look at
boom why is this one stuck here this is
so weird
know nobody's taken a tower
yet I would also like to know the levels
of these various things
see I'm do this so that it doesn't clog
memory yeah they took a tower
okay on a
entities is dot we got to put this here
so we
can we're going to get the levels I want
to see them level
okay mpai float 6 4
object is not
means I can't see this because it's
going too
fast so
16 and then we get to the really rare
bug that I have to
fix cool though
right I don't think that we've actually
given them stats yet so maybe that's
what we'll do maybe we'll do uh stat
scaling for a bit
because what I would like to have happen
is I'd like to at least have the the
ability for like I'd like to be able to
run this game super fast like that and
see that um you know eventually the
players just start murking the creep
waves or
whatever though the creep waves scale
pretty hard in Dota too don't they the
creeps get
stronger but still by the end you're
like one-shotting the creep waves
right
yeah okay I will be right back I'm going
to use a rest room then we're going to
do another hour on this and we are going
to um we're going to get something that
actually looks like a winnable game of
DOTA and I think we'll probably add in
the
um the Nexus objectives or whatever they
are Fountain no not Fountain
Nexus uh and then we'll like we'll set
the wi con of the game that'll be cool
be right
awesome what is the issue right
here oh there's no issue this is
literally just the gift
saving oh did we actually go through all
these
frames we simulated 10,000 frames that's
funny so there's no bug we just
simulated 10,000
frames faster than I thought we could
do we have any form of scaling in right
now
doesn't look like we have any form of
scaling
Mana we have their basic attack damage
set too basic
attack
basic oh wait I saw player dot here it
is reset player.
damage you have it set to
25 which is very low isn't it I think I
use Lena as the model for this it's
probably way too low give me another
hero um it's like a reasonable thing
to herob base damage what's like a
middle
tier damage
damage oh it's actually not that far
off the really high ones are like
30s agility
[Music]
Heroes okay so like some of them are
really slow really
low okay I think 30 is a good one to
start off
with and what's the scaling
what's like good scaling or like random
scaling
um attack damage scaling Dota
attribute does anybody just want to tell
me how
much how much scaling you get
roughly bonus attack
no what is
this
strength is it main attack damage per
point you get one damage per
point
right detailed
table main attack damage at level
one which what base attack damage and
Main attack damage oh because it's with
the scaling right okay so I was
underestimating drastically drastically
underestimating it should be more like
50 5050 base attack damage which is
about what a creep does
right is that what a creep hits maybe a
little
more yeah so you do about that amount of
damage so let's up this to
50 because we don't have strength
scaling or
how much do they get so we can
actually Max main attack
damage we can get it right here right
that the average is
like well depends on which how much they
scale uh 150 I'm seeing a lot of 150s
140s 160s
and what the heck some of these are like
crazy okay let's say 150
damage so it's 100 divided
30 so let's say three it's
90 is damage a float or an
INT it's a float so we'll do
3.3 self. Lev player.
xp. damage equals 50+ 3 3 times player
dot
and then the max Health as well goes up
right and Max
Mana we're going to have to organize all
this data I just want to get something
to start
with layer. Max
Health 500 and 100
okay
plus and now we need to
have player Health
right and no Health
scaling Talent grants them a flat Health
bonus
what is
the health
Health 20
hp 22 times base
strength plus level minus one time oh 22
* strength
so 22 times base
strength
so I don't know what the hell that's
going to equate to there's not a table
of level 30 health
strength agil oh here it
is damage damage
Max
this do we have health on here
anywhere
RG int T MS
T30 move
speed what the hell where's the where's
health is Health not in
here attack
speed well at least we see the HP and MP
per
know I'm just going to guess because I
don't know
they don't have 3,000 health I'm going
to say it's 50 Health a level so 2,000
at 30 I don't
know player.
plus well I'm going to actually leave
the Mana as is right now because I have
it I don't have that scaling set
up but I am going to actually make I'm
going to add a a very slow
heal I'm going to add
a player
dot if
player okay
so now if I rebuild
[Music]
this I think we should see him murking
some
level
[Music]
XP level
17 invalid XP
rebuild definitely the heroes are
they're still getting stuck in stuff at
places so we're going to have some
glitches to
fix but let's see if we can get these
things taking some towers and if this
doesn't work I'll make it
asymmetric because DOTA has like the
hard Lane and the safe Lane
thing okay so they both took each
other's mid
Towers uh one top T1 is Fallen
I think that they're uh the they're just
spamming their
skills and they're not actually hitting
with
them there nothing is happening because
they're already at level
26 so let's see about
that if you use Q
yeah these need to all be be to tell you
if they've used
them we're going to replace this with
basic attack for
now and the reason is just so that we
can tell uh I think that they spamming
skills without knowing what they're
doing using them for and as a result um
they're not like just using their basic
attack to kill NPCs which should be
incredibly effective once they're level
something let's just rebuild this and
try this
again oh it's Monday I actually I can
stream a little later today then
maybe at least while I'm getting stuff
done
fallen so ders lost two tier ones mid
and top
I could probably make a jungle AI
without too much difficulty
right
maybe is that yeah mid just lost tier
two
we're at
level radiant is at level 30 dire is
only at level 19 which is
odd but then if radiant is at level 30
they should be sweeping though I guess
they're not using abilities and there's
no scaling for item builds built
in they are pushed back very very far
though um but they are
holding I think it's because a couple
players keep getting
stuck or maybe just the the tier threes
are very very
strong the minions don't even have
scaling on them at the
moment so they should just be getting
wrecked though I guess again they're not
using spells and there's no they're no
items
on okay so the thing that we know will
definitely cause this it's a mirror
match so it's hard to say how long it
should take for somebody to like win
we're going to make this more DOTA style
um this
like one one2 jungle is a it's a league
thing let's make this more DOTA with the
lane
assignments this should
help we're going to
do okay we're going to
do the entity assignments again
so it's uh what is
it
support
06 and we actually need to swap
these
one
so 0 one
six
two is I these suggestions are so stupid
this is burst not
tank then this one is tank this one is
so we're going to
assign uh
support screw it support assassin and
carrye are all just going to go to the
safe Lane
so zero this is going to be lane
two one lane is also going to be
two and then uh what is
it entity four is going to be lane two
as well so this is the safe Lane then we
do self. get
entity uh the mid is going to go to one
and then get entity this will go to zero
okay so this is three one and one get
entity five is going to
be uh
Lane this is their support so their
support goes to their safe Lane which is
three so 5
six and then what is it their their uh
carry also goes there so
nine nine goes to three
and
then their uh burst goes to Lane
four and then their eight which is their
tank goes to the the off Lane so this
should be more the DOTA meta which is
actually way better for this the lane
assignments because uh it makes it
asymmetric so it makes it easier to see
a
result cuz the expectation there is that
they should both push into the to the
end of the game right because 3v
one okay let's see how fast this
happens
so not particularly fast no there's a
tower that's been
taken it's the wrong side though that's
supposed to be the
uh are the lane assignments
right I want to run this
slower now we're going to run this where
we can actually see what's going on okay
so they have three three assigned here
then one in
one yeah okay so this is
and maybe they don't have the attack AI
on I think they don't have the attack AI
on that's got to be it
AI move towards basic attack so they
don't actually need any of this [ __ ] at
all
right yeah cuz that's going to set the
cool down to be
Jank so we just are going to comment all
this skill
stuff and uh they're going to just use
the creep AI in their assigned lane and
then we're going to see what that does
for
us should be the same thing right it's
just that these guys scale so three of
these pushing down one lane should equal
win you win the game we're gonna run it
slow so I can catch bugs
maybe hold
is okay so they did get a wave
Advantage yeah so actually on the first
push they got all the way to the
tower uh and then they all went down
mid Okay so the lane assignments that
appear to be breaking
right yeah the lane assignments are 100%
breaking
so respawn
to uh where is this breaking
that the lane the lane assignments get
broken move
oh I have to reset the way points
right when you spawn the
creep you reset their Waypoint to
zero
do let's see if that fixes it because if
they were all going down mid then it's
not going to
work
okay so here we go here's our F first
push they get pretty far right they get
all the way to the the tower and here
they come
working yes it is I should probably swap
the colors with the
creeps um because the gray ones
are are the heroes in this case so
they've pushed to the
trickling they're only level four as
well which I base the scaling off of
DOTA so this would be very early to take
a tower
anyways uh radiant is now level 3.4 dire
is level 5.4 on
average I don't know why there's such a
big difference but hey who knows maybe
there's some weird as
symetry okay they're pushing to the
tower they're having a hard time it
looks like getting past the
tower which is reasonable because towers
are strong they do a lot of damage
they are pushing all the way to the
towers
though and then mid
is H not
much they pulled a neutral creep and it
was just hitting them that was funny
on hopefully the computer doesn't go
down this is ridiculous
it uh they should not be oing though
that's
weird I don't think I was appending the
frames to
this yeah this is locked
up there we go this is
script I don't know why that's
happening I should not be um saving the
frames
there you go it's the only one that
works I don't know
why
um that's a little bit of a bummer
what's
happening yeah I'm not a I'm not saving
the
frames right
that should not be ramping memory usage
something's wrong can't be any leaks we
don't allocate any memory dynamically so
something's just being cashed
[Music]
weird let's watch what happens
here so we're not going to play it we're
just going to watch what happens when
they play it for
us so here we have our bottom safe
fight right I'm not allowed to have the
mouse outside of the
screen I haven't fixed that bug yet
that's just a render bug
right yep lots of
damage I saw him getting
chunked I don't know what killed us at
the end there that was a lot of burst
damage to be
taking looks like they get stuck on the
tower way point for just a
moment and
then we are level two now so we have 600
Health do a little bit more
damage okay we died at a relatively
reasonable rate inside of a full pack of
minions
right not getting that much xp but then
again I have it set right now so you
only get XP on last
hits okay
I saw it did a lot of damage and tanked
a bunch of
stuff I'm not seeing anything
immediately wrong um it looks like I'm
going to have to fix that leak but um in
the meantime I'm guessing it's based on
frames and not simulation steps so I'm
just going to run it super fast and I'm
going to run it in the uh Raab mode
okay so here we
go we should be able to watch Towers
being taken
it does look like occasionally the AI
gets bugged because I can see on the
left there's a player that's just
Frozen radiant now has level 24 players
they should absolutely be taking this
bottom
up let me get HTP just to make sure
we're
not killing our memory no we're fine
whatever it was that caused that before
doesn't look like it was just uh we are
actually leaking memory very slowly
though
worries what the heck is going on why
aren't they taking
Towers oh there we
go radiant just took the uh their first
Tower in safe
oh and dire's taken one as well I just
didn't notice
it so yeah this is exactly how it's
supposed to work it's just being
slow uh I would expect this to have
happened by now so I guess the scaling
is just off